so we are happy to have victor gabillion
uh to give the last talk today
uh victor was a phd in india
and was a postdoc in queensland
university of technology and he's
currently in the industry
his work covers a wide range of uh wide
range of topics in band design
reinforcement learning specifically he
works uh
has done several works in best arm
identification pure exploration or
mainly max bond for expert problem and
he also have several
uh
have a lot of empirical projects in the
industry
and today he will be talking about based
on
identification and the best of both
worlds
thank you
everybody thank you for the introduction
thanks to the organizer for organizing
the workshop and having me
so
i'm presenting a joint work with yasina
basiat curry peter bartlett alan malek
and michel velco
and i'm going to start with a slide that
summarized the talk and
the work so we are going to talk about
bandit problem which is a best term
identification problem
because the goal will be to identify the
best arm so it's different from the
bandit problem you had in the previous
talk i will try to explain that
but as in the previous talk what we are
interested in is asking this
best of both world type of questions so
it means we're trying to have a learner
that is able
to work in a setting where the data is
generated stochastically or if actually
the data is designed to make it fail and
we wanted to perform in the stochastic
setting as if
he knew in advance that he was in a
stochastic setting and
we want to work it
we want it to work in the adverse
setting as if he knew he was against an
adversary so we saw in the previous talk
that it was possible to do it in a
classical bandit problem can you do it
in the best army notification problem
that's what we are going to look at
and the way we go about it is going
through the state of the art for the
stochastic setting then we'll look at
what does it change when you face an
adversary
this will lead us basically to ask the
best of our first question can we can we
achieve it we will have a first
impossibility result so actually in this
setting you cannot do it
but we will reformulate the question
and
we'll basically design an algorithm that
match the lower bound of the
impossibility result
so what is the best army notification
problem we formulate it here
in a fixed budget setting so you have an
exploration phase of fixed
length
basically there will be big t rounds and
the learner will try to identify the
best arm so the the arm which will
accumulate the most uh reward over the t
rounds and i insist that uh yes
it's a banded feedback so the learner
only observe the reward and the gain of
the arm that you choose to explore and
this is basically the protocol
so it goes for t rounds big t rounds and
at each round simultaneously you have a
learner that picks an arm denoted i t
here between 1 and k
then the reward is generated
by a process it can be addressable or
stochastic environment basically it
picks a vector of size k the number of
experts which tells the reward of each
expert
and the learner only observes one
component of that vector gt g-i-t-t
and finally at the end of this phase
this expiration phase the learner has to
recommend an arm which he thinks is the
best one the way we don't
denote that is with this big one
indexed by t sometimes we drop the
dependency in big t in um in a purple
box
uh and so that's its recommendation and
he hopes that he's actually making the
good recommendation so it's actually
recommending the
ground truth
best arm which we denote in green so
purple will be the point of view of the
algorithm and green will be the ground
roof and the ground roof here how we
define the best arm is the arm that in
hindsight has been allocated the most
reward and so the cumulative reward is
big gkt and it's basically the sum of
the gkt for that particular arm
okay
here i'm just introducing a simple
notation about ranking
so you have let's say you have a
bonded problem with four arms and at the
end of the game they have been allocated
cumulatively those rewards and then we
basically sort them by from the one
which has the most reward so our best
arm to the worst so here you have like
index three is wrong one and just the
notation is that if you give me a wrong
k
uh this thing tells you which
bandit
is ranked k according to the ground
truth
reward and the opposite is basically if
you give me an arm i can tell you
which rank it has with the diamond
notation and if we change color this is
from the point of view of the learner so
it's with an estimate of the
of the true one
okay
now i'm going to
kind of repeat what i said but just
illustrated graphically so that it will
help us discuss later
the problem
so we start with a banded problem here
we have just four arms i mean it could
be in terms of application different
products that you want to test you will
have a fixed
exploration i mean fixed number of tests
t-test and at the end maybe you want to
decide which one which one you put in
the market
uh it could be drugs that you test of a
t patient and then at the end you want
to see which one cure the best some
disease it could be potentially even
some experts that maybe each day they
give you an advice on how to run your
business and then you try to maybe hire
the one that gives you the best advices
over that test period
so yeah graphically yeah at every time
step we have a vector that is generated
of rewards the
the learner will pick an arm you have
this one and only get to see this reward
and basically it doesn't see the rest
time two is the same and then after t
time you have defined basically a big
matrix where the learner has only seen
part of it and most of it has been
not seen
and okay we denote this matrix g
and
here basically is the cumulative reward
that helps us define what is the best
term so it's basically the sum of the
column
in that particular case to be sure we
understand notation
here it would make sense for the learner
to basically recommend the expert with a
white background
but in that particular case could be a
mistake the expert with a little will is
actually the best if we if you look at
if you sum all the rewards
that have been seen or not seen
okay now i want to make a difference
between our setting the best army
notification setting and the
classical bandit setting so the
classical band setting would use the
cumulative regret
and for us we used as a measure of
performance the probability of error we
try to minimize the probability of the
united property of misidentifying the
best arm so our goal is to identify the
best arm and
while in the cumulative regret setting
the goal is to play the best arm most of
the time so you you basically are
penalized if you play a sub optimal arm
you are penalized well in our case we
are free totally to explore in our case
it's what's really called pure
exploration and in
classical blended case you have this
exploration exploitation tradeoff
okay so we are going to look at this
best term institution
problem under different assumptions over
the real world and this better
notification has been already studied in
some of
these cases so for example there has
been a lot of study in the stochastic
cases
where the gkt is sampled iid
from some unknown mean
and
sorry from some unknown distribution
that has some unknown meaning in uk
we'll actually look at
related work because we will base our
research on that
for the other days and then people have
been interested in looking at a
non-stochastic case basically drop the
iid
assumption and non-statuality assumption
because it makes sense
in practice to make algorithm more
robust and actually what we are going to
look at in this
talk is the extreme case where this
matrix g can be totally arbitrary
and in a worst case analysis can be
designed to make the learner totally
fail to make the probability of error as
big as possible
and this formulation has not been looked
at uh in the western identification
program but it's pretty similar to the
way it's formulated in the classical
adversary bandit
so now i'm going to
talk about some related work in the
non-stochastic setting
so
yeah it's a non-stochastic we have
actually an interesting work by uh kevin
jameson
um which was tailored to
hyper parameter optimization
so
the gkt in their case
were
non-stochastic but with the condition
that they would convert to a
fixed value as time goes to infinity
and also i want to mention that the way
they would gather the data is different
from us and maybe it's interesting to
look at this to understand better our
setting
so
this would be our setting this would be
the other setting in our setting at time
t what do we see
it's the
pink stars so if i i decided time t to
get some value from the expert to the
tie i would basically see this value and
there is no hope that i mean this time
goes like this so there is no hope at
those values i will ever see them they
are hidden for me forever
in their case
it was making sense to assume that if i
pulled the thai expert you would get to
see the next one in the pile
i also want to mention another algo
event that is doing best at a best time
notification non-stochastic case
uh so yeah things are totally
non-stationary there but we have um an
assumption in that or in the paper by
alicia fierron
which is that the best arm
the identity of the best time doesn't
change through time it has to be the
same over all the experiments and
actually
from my point from our point of view it
actually
removes some of the art case that we use
in our in our lower bounds so it removes
some hard cases
okay
so
now let's go and talk about the state of
the art in the stochastic setting that
we will use to build our algorithm in
the adversary setting so
what are the basic things you can do the
most basic thing you can do is to
explore totally uniformly so you have a
budget t and you divide it equally
between the arms tier okay
but okay that's not the smartest thing i
mean you can do something smarter
because intuitively once you start to
pull some arms some of them are clearly
suboptimal and you start saying okay
could save some budget stop pulling that
arm and pull more
other arms that i'm not sure about if
they are the best and to focus on the
best term so i'm going to talk about a
tiny bit more about successive reject in
the next slide
but before i want to mention that all
those algorithms classically they are
based on an estimate of the mean mu hat
kt which is the simple average i mean
just summing the the reward that you
have seen divided by the number of
rewards that you are seeing and this
will actually be biased when we go to an
adversary
and also i want to introduce a table
that i will try to populate through to
talk so so far there is not much we just
said that we are two algorithms here
and we have only talked about the
stochastic setting and we say that
uniform is not very good successive is
better and we have not talked about yeah
the adversarial case and okay i will try
to
let this table grow
but as i said first i'm going to say
explain what is successive reject
because basically our final solution
will be an extension of it
the successive reject is an elimination
algorithm you start with four experts
and you just play them uniformly for a
first phase and then you look at the
expected mean and you reject an arm here
let's say it's the thai expert so now
you reject you stop pulling it
then
so and yeah you reject it and then you
pull uniformly the three remaining arms
at the end of phase two you reject
another arms here is this one and you
just continue pulling the two last one
and then at the end you make a
recommendation the important thing in
successive reject is how long are those
phases and the intuition is that it is
that it works because it does the
following thing it tries to pull the arm
that is
a ranked k with an estimated rank k
uh just to give it a number of pull
which is industrially proportional to
his estimated long so it has two of okay
basically uh the estimated best arm has
almost t pool the estimated second best
arm has almost
half of all the pools the estimative
service time a third and this has nice
property because i mean
in some sense you pull everybody almost
uniformly you play the two best arm uh
as if the rest of the arm did not exist
and you play almost the best time almost
all the time
so this is something that we will
basically reuse
in later slides
but okay so right now i'm still in the
stochastic setting and
uh i explained the algorithm but i
haven't given the
like some theoretical results here
actually the probability of error and so
we want to characterize the property of
error to be able later to compare
stochastic setting with adversarial
setting so let's look at how you analyze
those algorithm
basically in a stochastic setting you
need to define
some kind of notion of complexities
and
let's start with a simple example if you
have two arms but i want to discriminate
this this is the final cumulative reward
we have
uh of course there will be noise so you
will have some noisy estimate and you
might make some mistake but the more you
you get pulled the more your estimate
goes to the mean and if you use a
turn-off dim type of result
uh you can
you what will happen in the analysis is
that it will tell you that
the number of i mean the number of pools
somehow that you need to use so that you
are able to discriminate those two arms
with high priority depends on this
complexity h which is
one over the gap square and the gap
square i mean the gap is just the
difference between them so the smaller
the gap the harder it is to discriminate
them so this was for two arms now if you
have k arms what you expect to have is
just the sum over the inverse gap
squared and that's almost
what you're going to have
because basically the the intuition in
the stochastic case
and which will not be true actually
against an adversary is that to
discriminate the best arm
from the fourth best arm you need to
have confidence interval around the
value which is
smaller than half the gap so that the
confidence interval do not overlap
okay and so what do we actually get
this is the complexity that we get for
the uniform algorithm it's not the sum
of the inverse gap squared because
uniform is not a good algorithm it's k
times
the minimal gap and successive reject
gets something which is actually close
very close to the sum of the inverse gap
squared up to some lock k factor and the
way it looks is this like a max
of the index divided by the
corresponding the gap squared
okay
so where are we right now we just uh
finished talking about the stochastic
setting and we have that the probability
of error there
decrease it decreases actually
exponentially
so exponential minus t over the
complexity so the bigger the complexity
the bigger the error
and we have that the state of the art is
to have this complexity h of sr in
stochastic setting
but so now
what can we do against an adversary
let's just like take the vanilla
successive reject and throw it against
an adversary and see how it works
basically it will fail
because the adversary is just powerful
you can arrange any
matrix g of reward so here i have an
example of successive reject against
adversary
successive reject if it's the vanilla
version and plays totally
deterministically the adversary knows
that you're not going to see that value
you can just put it to an arbitrary
value and confuse you
second thing is that you have those
elimination phases you reject alarm
forever and this is bad against an
adversary because for example this thai
expert
you are basically saying that i totally
ignore all the rewards that are here and
the way we define our problem is that we
won't find the expert that has the
highest
accumulated reward so we count
everything
and in adversarial setting there is no
reason why
this thing would be related to that so
you will be super biased
and basically in general using
the
this estimation of the mean the standard
one will be biased against an adversary
so the takeaway is that probably you
need internal randomization not reject
and use probably something with smaller
bias
i think that's what we do
okay
so now where are we we have two
algorithms that work in the stochastic
case and that failed against another
survey
the question is like okay what can we do
against an objective
so the first idea that you want to test
is let's take the uniform algorithm the
uniform allocation exploration algorithm
and let's just robustify it a little bit
and see how it works
so
basically we use internal randomization
we introduce now a probability of
pulling um i t at time sorry
k at time t
and in the for uniform algorithm it's
simply one over k and the second thing
we do is we replace
the estimation of the mean by
the importance weight
estimation of the mean
where now when you see a reward you
divide it by the probability that you
would see that reward so the good thing
is that it's unbiased the bad thing for
the next of the talk is that it actually
increased the variance because if this p
is small this quantity is large and it
will have a high variance but so far for
our robust uniform learner
and we wouldn't
yeah let's say so this is just the
algorithm and so how does it work
against an adversary
you can simply it's a simple proof to
show that actually the uniform
allocation against an adversary is as
good as if it was against um
in the stochastic case again you have a
quality of error the diminished
exponentially fast with h unit appearing
okay but okay uniform is the baseline
we know it's not that small
can we do better
actually the thing is that in general
you can't
against
an adversary with a worst case scenario
you just cannot
do better than uniform it's pretty sad
results it kind of means that the
problem is so hard that um
just doing the basic thing is not
improvable
but it's not the end of the story uh
we'll talk about that later actually
uh but first yeah yeah first let's look
at a sketch of proof and how this
like somehow the address has more power
so i can confuse quite a lot
of the learner
basically
the arguments that we use are based on a
classical argument in
the literature
the thing that
is that we have a new construction here
and we have a new construction because
now we are dealing with i mean compared
to the stochastic case because we have
an adversary and he has much more power
and what will happen is that the
adversary somehow now it can force the
learner
to have an uncertainty around its mean
of all the arms over the
delta one and not delta k
previously i said oh to discriminate arm
k from the best sum you needed to have
an uncertainty over the
delta k now actually for all the arms
you need delta one
which is much smaller and it makes the
print too hard
all right
harder
what is actually the construction
so basically give me any learner give me
any bonded problem that we define only
for the first half of the game
and then
i will say okay that learner playing
that particular problem will play alarm
not a lot
let's say for this let's say that here
let's fix that it's the the worst arm i
mean that's kind of what should happen
so the the expert to the wheel and
basically you can say that he will play
it less than t over 2k time
and so basically because the learner
doesn't pull this arm a lot we can
use that to trick him
how do we trick him we create a second
problem
which is pretty similar the only
difference here is that
this expert now has just a value that is
been increased by just delta one if we
superpose the two problem
and the problem is that those
uh the problem for the learner is that
those two problems are in quite
indistinguishable from the point of view
of the learner basically when he will
see observation playing the game it will
be hard to say for him if he's facing
that problem of that problem
and at first it could it look like it
doesn't really matter because this is
not the best arm
so why would i care about that arm
actually because it's an adversarial
setting now we can define this problem
for the second half of the game and if
in the second half of the game i just
deterministically change the value of
that arm and make it in one of the prem
the best one and and the other problem
the second best one
now i have two problems
that look very similar and where in one
you should recommend the bandit with a
wheel and the other one you should
recommend the bandit with
the glasses
yeah sorry the arm of the wheel and the
arm or the arm with
the glasses
uh so then the lower bound comes from
that like you we have two problems
and
it will from the point of view of the
line it will be hard to know which
problem he is
but he has to make a decision and he has
to choose between the expert with
glasses and the expert with a wheel
basically the the right argument is to
use a
change of measure and consider the event
when
you should like of recommending
the
woman with glasses
and basically because prem 1 and prime 2
are very close to each other the
probability of those two are related
with the relation being that being how
close they are and you know that in this
world that's what you should do you
should recommend the woman with
glasses as an expert
and so this thing needs to be super
close to one otherwise it's bad and so
because it's super close to
because it's super close to one then you
have a lower bound on the error you do
on the second problem
so that's how you get the lower bound
and as i said like
i'm sad uh
in the other in addressable case in the
worst case you cannot do better than
uniform but it's not the end of the
story because right now
what is happening we have an algorithm
that works well in a stochastic setting
that fails in against an adversary in
this vanilla version
and we have something uniform that we
know is not that good
in a stochastic setting
but it works very good against an
adversary so naturally then you want to
ask the best of both world questions
can you have an algorithm that basically
get those two rates
sorry those three are here but those
traits at the same time being optimal in
both while not knowing if
the environment will be stochastic or
adversarial
and we have been inspired basically by a
lot of work in the classical bandit case
where which has been studying that
question
in in their case they could achieve the
best of both world as you have seen
uh so what can we do in our case
actually in our case we cannot
uh we cannot achieve
those two rates at the same time and to
understand that we need to introduce a
new notion
this notion is here hbob
um for best of both worlds
you see that this
notion oh yeah this notion of complexity
is defined for the stochastic case not
for the adversarial case for those
students case
you see that the way it's formulated it
has it borrows some
some of the
complexity from sr and from some of the
complexity for itunes
and let's look at the let's look
actually at the lower bound the lower
bound is saying that if there is an
algorithm
that claims that it can solve all the
uh bandit problem against an adversary
actually here it's even weaker than that
we just ask we if he just claims that
his property of error is smaller than
one over 16. i mean in the end we want
to have something that actually then is
choosing but
just if he claims he can do better than
one over 16 for all the elijah problem
then you can build a stochastic
problem where the
priority of error
will be bigger than
something where h-bob will appear and
the problem with that is that h-bob in
some cases is h of s-r times square root
of k so you have something it's
worsening by square out of k in the one
skills
you cannot have the best of both worlds
this is the end of the story and
not yet we can still do something
but we'll talk about that a tiny bit
later first i'm going to give an idea of
how the adversary can
trick the learner to get this lower
bound
so what is the construction there
here
we said in a stochastic setting you need
to have uncertainty over delta k over
all your arm yeah it's still the same an
adversary will force you to have an
uncertainty
of
of order delta k between all your arms
but he will force you to have that
earlier in the game before you had to do
that to have that at the end of the game
at time t here the adversary forces you
to have that amount but amount of
uncertainty at time t
delta 1 over delta k and this is smaller
than 1 because delta 1 is the smallest
gap
why why is that let's look at the
construction
so we start with basically any branded
problem and this bandit problem will be
actually how the
adversary will attack the learner
so
give me a learner give me actually any
rank k which
in
arm
and
we have this problem that we define only
for between the start of the game until
this t over delta 1 delta k so that's
the length of the attack
let's look at how the learner play this
problem
again we identify an arm that is not
played enough and we will try to fool
the learner by modifying this arm so
we will say that there is at least one
arm called k prime
among
the best k arms that is pulled at less t
over k delta 1 delta k
and here we illustrate that taking a an
example where i choose i choose
arbitrarily that k will be equal to four
so it's the worst arm
and
let's say that here the learner the the
arm that is not pulling
that much is actually also the worst arm
actually if it was any other arm it
would mean that the learner is even
less smart like if he was not putting
the best arm most of the time
it would be even the worst case for him
so let's even imagine that the learner
is smart he is pulling the worse under
the less still we can trick him so the
worst time right now is the real expert
and so how can we trick
from the attack and defining now the
actually the stochastic
problem
in the stochastic problem now the real
expert is the best arm
so this problem is
yeah this problem is defined from time
one to time t
and now now i have my stochastic problem
how do i define
my adversary my adversary will first do
the attack
and then pretend is the stochastic
problem so
first you will do
that all the arms do not change
only the only change is here
uh so for
a short attack the adversary will uh
pretend that uh i mean we'll give
rewards of that magnitude
and then at the end of the attack he
will just come back to this one and
pretend it's the stochastic setting for
most of the time so it will be hard to
distinguish it with the stochastic
setting and it does that so that at the
end in hindsight when the exploration
phase is finished
his total cumulative reward is
this one so compared to the um
[Music]
setting we have managed to decrease the
the value of that arm
because of the attack of order delta one
so the attack is about use of magnitude
data delta k i mean delta four here and
it's short enough
so that we have changed the value of
this arm by delta one and basically now
we have two problems again where the
identity of the best arm is different
so
two problems that look very similar
actually the probability of confusion
here is exponential minus
t delta 1 delta k which looks like the h
probe that we have at the end because
there is the term in delta k
and this comes from the fact that i mean
our attack is of magnitude delta k and
the time it lasts is t delta 1 delta k
and
that's basically how it confused
[Music]
now basically you take
maximum over k and you get
your lower bound
so what is our result is that
it's impossible to get the best of both
worlds
because we get you have to be at least
as worst
as h-bob in the in the stochastic
setting
so is it the end of the story no hbob
sometimes is bad compared to hsr but
it's not that bad all the time so
basically hbob is in between h of sr and
h
you can see that even like just looking
at the equation because it kind of
borrows parts of hsr and h and if it has
the one over minimal gap and the max of
1k divided by delta k it's just doesn't
have the squares and if we look at
how h-bob varies between hsr and h-unif
you can look at specific cases in the
flat regime where you have just this is
like the how the arms are good so the
flat regime when you are just one good
arms and all the other arms are the same
i mean actually in this case all those
quantities are the same you just need to
play uniformly in this case
um if the landscape of the means
is linear then actually you can achieve
the best of both worlds because each of
us are is the same as h-pop but
definitely playing uniform there would
be would not be smart
and the interesting interesting case is
the square root regime
that looks like a squad there h bob is
exactly in the middle that's where we
have a lower bound it's because h bob is
square with k worse than hsr but it's
better than h unif so because hbob is
better than h leaf i mean it means we
still don't have an algorithm that
can achieve
the lower bond that we have in our
impossibility result so now we can
reformulate the best of both world
problem by asking can we have an
algorithm that reach now those rates h
bob and h unif i mean h-bob in a
stochastic case and each unit against an
adversary
so then the remaining challenge is
how do we define this algorithm what
type of estimator do we use you could
try to use the the biased one or the
unbiased one but with eye valence
we go for the one which is unbiased
but with high variance
and this form of variance is quite
significant and comes very fast actually
because we said the variance come from
the fact that we divide by pkt
and pkt if it's small this thing is big
and
gives us big variance
so
actually when i say big
if it's one of a k
it's big
and one over k is what you do when you
pull uniformly and uniformly is the
thing you have to do at the beginning of
the game when you have no information
you have to pull in your formally so you
will encure at the beginning uh
uh variance over decay but if you manage
to
stop pulling those arms
the best arm
with uh probability one of the can you
start to put them more often
your final total variance will be um
will be not of order one other key so
the other okay so what you need to do is
contain this uncertainty contain this
variance by starting to pull the best
arm early because the best time are the
ones on which you want to have smaller
uncertainty small vines you need
basically to do early bets start to say
start yeah start to pull the best time
earlier but
i mean somehow it's hard because it's
kind of a chicken and egg problem like
your goal is to find the best arm and
i'm telling you that if you want to find
the best arm you need to pull the best
arm more so there is a raise
and so what algorithm are we going to to
test basically we take successive reject
and we do two things we robustify it and
we do those early bets
so to robustify it we basically use the
unbiased estimator
we make sure that we don't pull
uniformly things like successive reject
which pulls basically all the arms for
half of the time almost
uniformly
by making some early bits as you would
see
we removed the rejection no rejection
but we used we use the core idea which
is to
pull
every arm inversion is proportional to
the estimated rank
so what does the algorithm look like
it's very simple
the same thing at every time step you
try to pull the estimated best arm with
probability one the estimated second
best arm with 31 half third the best one
with 480 one third and so on and the
worst arm is for scope is pulled with
481 over k
and okay it doesn't sum up to one so we
normalize
and this is just a lock k because the
sum of uh the one over case is okay
and so again we have this nice property
that most of the time we play the best
arm the two best arm are played as if
the rest were not existing and
it's kind of everybody's pulled almost
uniformly
and the cost is just a lucky and we have
the fact that we are doing early bets
the thing is that even at time t equal
to
we start to pull the estimated best arm
almost all the time so we have those
early bets
and
it actually
basically will work
this is again the algorithm it's just a
two-line algorithm
just
ranking the arms according to the
inverse estimator pulling industrially
inversely proportional to the frequency
to the
rank estimated rank and then at the end
recommending the arm that has the
highest unbiased estimator and this is
an algorithm which is actually any time
and parameter it doesn't even yeah
basically parameter
and just a fun fact is that um
actually this distribution which is to
allocate things one over
uh
their rank of
one over wrong has actually some a name
and
it doesn't appear on this slide but
later but okay it has a name which is
zinf
for this uh distribution and you
actually see it
uh
when you look at the frequency of words
in the english dictionary basically the
word that you see the most is the in the
english dictionary and it's
frequent twice as much frequent that the
second one that you see the most which
is off three times as much as the third
word which is end and so on
and so if we analyze uh this algorithm
p1 we actually get the best of both
worlds up to lock k factors
so we get h bob in a stochastic setting
we get h unif against an adversary
and
that's basic yeah
let's kind of kind of conclude our
search we can um
start to look a bit at the proof i mean
actually the proof of this algorithm
there is very easy against an adversary
because we pull things uniformly and
that's all it's needed against an
adversary but in a stochastic setting
you need to be able to
[Music]
make sure that the variance is very
small so the way you will analyze this
algorithm is by creating some
virtual phases
this actually phases doesn't do not
exist in the algorithm the algorithm has
no phases it's just
here
for the analysis and so what you want is
at that time t1 which is parameters by
a1 you want this event
the event i to be true
and you want it to be true very fast and
you want it to be true very high
priority so this event is good it's just
saying that you basically walk wrong
well all the
arms the
the arms that are supposed to be the
from one to the eye best the eif the if
best arm are supposed to be wrong among
the if pest
and this is something you want because
it means that from now on if
when this events start to be true it
means that now the probability that you
pull them start to be big and now you
know that you don't incur any more big
volumes after
this event is true but in when you do
the analysis then there is actually like
um
a trade-off i mean there is an optimal
value for a1 because we both want this
event to be true
uh very early but to be truly high
priority and if you do the analysis you
end up with this complexity in the
probability of error which depends on
the length of your face
and the one that seems to be good
is to
take ai i mean to take the ti so that
of this quantity and this quantity is
the quantity that we had also in the
lower bound which was the length of the
attack so the length of the attack is
also the length of the
before the event are true actually and
so if you plug that there you get back
hbob
up to some lucky factors
and
basically my last slide
you can now
test
the stochastic setting p1 to see if it
works according to the
what was forecasted by the fury
uh
basically you don't expect piranha so p
one here is in yellow you don't expect
it to be better than successive object
it should be in between
and
you basically want to know if it kind of
corresponds to the
the probability of error
matches the the complexity that you can
compute on those problems and let's say
i mean i'm not going to go into detail
but let's say it globally does i mean
not otherwise you have good control
example in the uniform case but like
in the case where edge bob is achievable
it is achieved and in the case where
the hardest case for
we talked about the square root
experiment is actually also the one
where
the ratio between the property of error
or versus two is actually the biggest
and that's it basically
uh can you actually use sequential heavy
instead of setting checks to do the
exactly same thing because actually the
more like a state-of-the-art algorithm
competitors had to check for fixed
budget first time identification
definitely you should never reject
permanent vietnam but
so rejecting this is bad but maybe you
could use the proportions that aren't
sequentially having yes which are very
close to the ones that are here
maybe we improve the bond actually
look at it
but
like at the level of precision that i
have
maybe we might improve the location sure
but
yeah with that algorithm we
so the only thing that is left to
improve is
so you you made the distinction in the
when you discussed the non-stochastic
best identification from the literature
but essentially you see the next
essentially all the draws are
pre-decided and you see them
sequentially rather than
rather than essentially only seeing one
and everything you have this figure
right i guess
yeah this is our setting where let's say
this is tiny
and this is the big thing i don't think
that i would see can you discuss why we
have this difference between the two
settings
like i guess
in my understanding is that the
left-hand side is the previous set right
yes
okay
and i guess i think it was making sense
in their application that
in application they could see everything
it's just that
those values
i see so different
i guess
so what is exactly so in that setting
you see what
you see the next one
so since nothing we need
everything is not recycled and that just
puts very bad things happening in the
end
them like them
yeah but
this will not can use that
so regarding this discussion that if you
forget about this condition that is not
work
uh
is there a difference
between
two settings
is there a provable difference in the
hardest of two settings
even if you don't assume that things
converge
maybe if things
is
thank you all for the
participation today